Oh
well the thing that I learned while I
was there much to my surprise was the
well there were several things one was
the defensive pneus of journalists which
I should have no known having been a
journalist myself for several decades
secondarily the the impact of what's
said in The Times its enormous and I
think even more so today even though the
papers under attack than it was five or
ten years ago because as other news
organizations are weakened as you see
yet another cut in the staff of this
newspaper or of that television network
The Times which has had very few cuts
relatively speaking becomes yet more
important it's the place where the rest
of the news industry turns for its news
it's where the rest of the news industry
goes to get its leads on what's
important the day that came home to me
very very clearly during the time that I
was there all the more reason why it was
essential is essential for the time to
do the best possible job and all the
more reason for its journalists not to
be defensive about it because as the
best of them will say if I make a
mistake I want to know I want to be able
to correct it
when I arrived people were very very
dubious and and in some cases openly
hostile a few remained hostile for the
entire period that I was there but by
and large I think they learned that
though I could say whatever I wish to
say in my column in the paper I was not
speaking for their bosses I was speaking
for myself though it could be
embarrassing being raging they come in
the morning on monday after my column
appeared on sunday and it was spilled
their newspaper wasn't my newspaper so
the the more extreme hostility did begin
to fade away although no no one likes a
cop I was internal affairs except I was
not representing the institution I was
internal affairs from the outside no one
wanted to see my name on the call I call
her ID box because I couldn't be calling
about good news no one wanted to see me
coming to walk up to their desk I
wouldn't be there because somebody had
written to me to say what a good job the
journalists did I was I was the bearer
of bad tidings
well the toughest thing peculiar was not
about something that had happened while
I was at the paper the toughest thing
was dealing with the times's coverage of
weapons of mass destruction in the bush
administration's reasons for going to
war in 2003 I arrived at the paper in
December of 2003 after the scandal the
Jayson Blair scandal I like to refer to
myself as the unwanted love child of
jayson blair & howell reigns after
reigns was replaced by Bill Keller they
then created this job they brought me in
but the thing that seemed to continue to
nag and a huge portion of the readership
and a very large portion of people on
the staff was what had happened before
and I had established as a rule when I
began I can't write about things that
happened before I came to the times
because I'd be writing about the
coverage of the Holocaust which the
times did a very bad job I'd be writing
about the cutting the types of coverage
of Stalin which I did a horrible job on
I would disappear into the mists of
history nonetheless over a period of
months after I arrived there I realized
that the absence of the times's own
coverage of its own mistakes was fair
for me to comment on the time should
have been writing about what it had
gotten wrong what it and the rest of the
press had gotten wrong so the absence
that the x is failure to cover that
became I thought justification for me to
write about it and that was without
question less controversial issue among
readers and also people at the paper as
it happened it was received pretty well
at the paper there were very few people
who were proud of that coverage it was
also true that the management how
arranged and Gerald Boyd they were gone
from the paper but there was still a few
people in important positions who had
been responsible for some of the bad
coverage and they weren't very happy
with what I did then the next most
consequential thing was that I was there
during the 2004 personal campaign and of
my advice to all who would contemplate
becoming public editor of the times
don't do it during a presidential
campaign because half the people are
going to be displeased with absolutely
everything that appears in the paper so
on one day there would be this picture
of John Kerry looking foolish let's say
stupid grin on his face and there would
be this wave of emails and phone calls
and people does in the office saying
this proves that the x is anti
Carrie they didn't notice the picture of
Bush looking foolish the day before
because they expect Bush to look foolish
and vice versa if there were a picture
of a smiling John Kerry you know looking
great in heroic the bush supporters
would complain that see your supporting
supporting carry not having noticed that
they had run in somewhat picture of Bush
the day before and so it would headlines
captions photographs everything
displeased angered half half the people
and I found that I came a kind of little
construct a philosophical construct
about it which is the people
particularly things they care about as
they read the newspaper or encounter
news from any other source they what
what they encounter which conforms to
their view of the world they accept this
fact and that which does not conform to
their view of the world they think is
bias not different they think it's
biased and invisible divided times it
makes it very very hard to put out a
newspaper and not be perceived and small
in one way or the other
there's a great displeasure about
anonymous sources and though the times
has made an effort to put that phrase
after according to a source who remained
chose to remain anonymous because he
didn't want to make his boss angry or
whatever it might be or didn't have
permission to talk that mitigates it a
little bit but what I found and this did
surprise and dismay me because even
though I've always been suspicious of
anonymous sources myself I have in fact
use them as in my career as a journalist
is that readers thought that the
reporter was making that up readers says
you know here's a quotation about what
went on in the you know behind closed
doors in the White House and according
to a highly placed source and readers
thought well that was the reporter
wanted to get his or her thoughts into
the piece it really didn't happen and
that if you stop to think about it I
mean there can be can't imagine anything
that is more destabilizing and
potentially ruinous to the reputation of
journalists than people thinking that
the generals are making things up I
would have come to believe that we're
much better off if the journals puts it
in his or her own voice makes the
assertion without quotations that this
is what was discussed behind closed
doors then we know who it's coming from
in whom to blame and I see that name at
the top of it and I say do I trust that
person well you know if it's David
Sanger for instance that you you bet I
trusted because he has a wonderful
record of being right and I don't need
to have this invented or not invented
I'm sorry I don't need to have this this
ghost the scepter this unnamed source be
there as an authority because that
source is not an authority if he or she
does not have a name there's a lot of
questioning among readers about the
relationship between journalists and
their sources so that for instance when
I was at the paper two very senior
journalists and the Washington bureau
chief several people in Washington girl
had dinner with Condoleezza Rice and it
was reported and I don't know where it
showed up but did you know it was a
friendly dinner it shows up in you know
a society column a gossip column
whatever it might be and that led a lot
of readers to say wait I thought you're
supposed to be policing these guys I
thought you're supposed to be you know
holding Condoleezza
and her policies at arm's length but if
you're pausing around with them if
you're buddy-buddy with them then can we
really trust you so there was a lot of
anger from the left from Democrats over
that and just as I imagined there would
be if it were you know now if it were
you know Hillary Clinton sitting down
and having a pleasant dinner with people
the there is a lot of doubt about among
readers about whether journalists can
really be honest about people with whom
they have decent social relations and I
think in some cases their their right to
have that doubt although generally not I
think that it is a measure of a good
journalist that you're willing to not
stab your friends in the back but if you
stab them in the front that's okay